hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today I'm going to be showing
you how I made 1.4 mil in an hour of
doing this method it's very easy very
low risk and uh we are buying from a
shop it's going to be on the lunar Isles
so you will need um lunar diplomacy
completed and about 5 uh to 10 mil
starting cash all right let's get
started so uh B's magic shop is on the
lunar Isles um she mainly sells runes
but also has some other stuff what we're
mostly looking for are the battle stabs
as well as um some of the runes so if we
hop over to G tracker G tracker is a
sponsor of mine uh they have a bunch of
useful tools for tracking the prices of
the grand exchange they have buy limit
uh they have pretty upto-date
information as of the last half an hour
as of the prices and um there will be a
link in the description for that if you
guys are interested and haven't heard me
ramble on about them already forever um
anyway so we can see the death runes
have a pretty high price as of today
upwards of 330 which is really really
good if we have a look at the nature
Rune it's at about 263 which is pretty
awesome as well and uh the battle stabs
always have a good one 1 to 1.5k margin
on them uh leading us to get a pretty
hefty amount of profit um from this
method so we'll go ahead hop into the
lunar Isles and I will show you how it
works all right guys uh so for this
method you will need a lunar diplomacy
completed uh beyond that you'll just
need about 5 mil I'm taking 10 just to
be certain but um you realistically will
only need about five uh from here you
will need to go to the moonclan island
now the lunar spell book has the
quickest teleport but you can also use
the home teleport as well um if you
don't have the magic level or something
like that uh from here uh you're going
to run a little bit up to the north and
there's going to be a house uh walking
around which uh makes a little more
sense when you see it there it is and
what we're going to do is go inside and
talk to uh Baba Yaga she is going to
sell battle stabs
and death runes and nature runes is
mostly what we're going to be interested
in also the astral runes I'm going to
test that out and see if that is worth
it as well all you're going to do buy
battle stabs buy death runes all the way
down to at the current price about 200
uh but easy way to check this is just
check the value of the death Rune 259
and then examine it uh giving you the G
price of 321 uh so we'll definitely go
ahead buy a couple more hit value again
and just keep doing that until uh the
price is roughly up to to the GE price
um buy nature runes and um yeah so we're
going to go ahead do this for an hour
really easy just hop worlds once you buy
everything out oops didn't buy any more
of those and yeah we'll check back in in
a little bit all right guys we have
about uh 20 minutes left and uh just
worth noting is that the astal runes are
definitely worth buying as well um you
can kind of notice that um if you look
at the value 133 and on the grand
exchange uh they're 184 you can can
actually buy these all the way uh until
they're zero in the shop and they will
still be profitable so it's definitely
worth buying those as well as you notice
I bought quite a few astral runes uh a
little bit less death runes and not that
many nature runes uh but yeah we'll
finish off the last uh 20 15 minutes or
so and we'll see how much we actually
made all right guys uh that is about an
hour just a couple minutes over an hour
finishing up our last run uh so we'll go
ahead and price check uh to see how much
it looks like it's going to be worth uh
looks like about
1.3 mil in profit and remember we
started with the 10 mil uh but we'll go
see we'll go ahead and uh sell
everything for the high price uh just to
get the most value out of it and see how
much we actually profited so we'll
teleport back to the Grand exchange
unfortunately since we're on luminary
Spellbook um you can't use ack teleport
um and yeah we'll pop everything into
the ground exchange and see how much
it's worth all right death ruines we can
sell for 323 each perf perfect uh let's
check nature runes nature runes are
worth
263 astral runes are worth
184 pop those in there to
sell and the big one battle
stabs are going to be worth
8848 might not even be worth trying to
get maximum value of it but whatever
8848 and yeah we'll pop back when
everything is
sold okay so everything has sold on the
grand Exchange uh very quick only 5
minutes before everything had totally
sold uh so we're going to go ahead hit
collect and see how much we actually
made in 1 hour of buying from the babby
Gaga shop uh split collect and we're up
to 11 mil we'll go ahead and price check
this for you guys and looks like we made
uh about what the price check was
earlier so about 1.3 1.4 mil in just 1
hour and while um finishing lunar
diplomacy is a somewhat higher
requirement the method itself is really
easy really safe
and once you have the items easy to sell
off and 1.4 mil is not too shabby at all
um so I hope you guys enjoyed and if you
want to see more episodes like this on
the lunar spell book I know this wasn't
exactly the lunar spell book but it's
from uh unlocked by the lunar diplomacy
Quest um leave a comment or leave a like
on the video and uh I will see you guys
in the next
one
n